she is the embodiment like she's the
source of body is the guy I don't know
how to say it and so because of that
she's the one who gave body to Christ
maybe that's the best way to to think of
that if you understand it's like
Christ's body doesn't come from anywhere
else besides her like that's out of
which his body is it comes and so she
becomes a stand-in for the church for
all of us she's a stand-in for all of us
that is she is that which gathers us
she's the one who gathers us
toward gathers Us in worship towards
Christ is a good way to understand it
right uh and so and so because of that
that's why also she can appear
in in let's say she will appear in
Visions as well because she is that so a
good example is of course I don't know
if you know the
she often appears in images of
protections for example uh famous
Orthodox images the the veil of
protection so there's this in the
Constantinople someone had a vision of
her you know above the church and hold
putting her veil as a protection around
the church and so there are versions of
that in Catholic art where you've seen
you've probably seen these images where
you see the mother of God standing up
and then she has her cloak open and then
in her cloak is like standing all the
people right they're all gathered
together in her and so that's a good way
to understand it it's like she is that
she's the the Gathering of the body and
so she she stands in for the church
itself
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
let me begin my name is Margarita Mooney
Clayton I am the founder and director of
Scala Foundation uh which is based in
Princeton New Jersey where I'm an
assistant professor of practical
theology scala's mission is to renew
culture through bringing Beauty into art
and education and our faith communities
I'm delighted today to host Jonathan
peggio who is an artist based in
Montreal Quebec Canada he's also the
founder and director of the symbolic
World project which hosts blogs and
YouTube videos and I first encountered
him in fact as perhaps many of you did
through one of his many YouTube videos
then I began to look at his website and
saw a beautiful carvings of the Virgin
Mary different
um images icons and I began to read and
listen to his videos and I thought this
guy should be speaking at scala's next
conference which is April 21 in 22 in
Princeton New Jersey
this coming year 2023 and the topic is
Art the sacred and the common good if
you haven't heard about that conference
we'd love to see you there in person it
will also be live streamed so Jonathan
welcome thank you for being here yeah
thanks for having me it's great to see
all these people I put it in you know
the Mosaic mode or whatever looking at
everybody actually a few faces people
that I know so that's also wonderful so
it's nice to nice to be here thanks
great yeah so
the title of our conversation today
right I picked the image of Mary and the
burning bush The Exodus but before I
started in that I wanted to just kind of
say the reason I wanted to have you here
is that I want to speak through Scala
Foundation to artists who are trying to
live out this vision of art as
contributing to community and memory and
identity one of my favorite writers on
culture is a philosopher named Joseph
peeper I don't know if you've ever read
him but in his book Leisure the basis of
culture I didn't realize it until I Was
preparing to speak to you that some of
those essays sorry some of the essays
and only the lover sings pardon me were
talks he gave at a sculptor's studio
so he was friends with artists and one
of the things he says is that art
flowering from contemplation does not so
much attempt to copy reality as rather
to capture the archetypes of all that is
such art does not want to depict what
everybody sees but to make visible what
not everybody sees
so when I listened to you Jonathan
talking about the meaning of the mystery
of of the story of the burning bush and
how the burning bush is actually a
Marian prototype a lot of questions
emerged into my mind but I think one of
the things that you said that I wanted
you to say a little bit more about in
your video is you said that reality
comes to us veiled
and needs to be unveiled and in this
process of unveiling we have mediators
can you tell us a little bit more what
you mean that reality comes to us veiled
and needs to be unveiled through through
mediators and is the art that you make
supposed to is it actually claiming to
help unveil reality for us
um so I would say
well first of all it's important to
understand in some ways the mystery of
unveiling or the mystery of Revelation
but even the term Revelation is very
ambiguous because on the one hand it
seems to be showing you but then it's
it's actually veiling so it's like the
showing unveiling is it sounds like it's
complicated it's not that complicated
the way to understand it is that
let's say Unity or identity manifest
Itself by several characteristics we
often don't have access directly to to
the one we have access to the many right
that's the body that represents itself
like you you see the different aspects
of something and those aspects both Veil
and unveil like they show you they Point
towards identity but at the same time
because they're a particularization of
that one they act as something like a
veil now this is of course
represented in Sacred Space very clearly
if you look at the the pattern of the
Tabernacle in scripture this is what's
going on so what you have at the at the
outset is you have the very presence of
God that that manifests itself in the
holy of holies right the very source of
all reality which descends and connects
with the Earth but it's as if that Unity
is too much like it's just too much to
handle in some ways it's almost like you
couldn't even
see it it's too simple maybe as a good
way to understand it and so then it has
to be mediated think of it as a seed for
example if I showed you a seed and I
said
like you know this is a tree and you're
like well that's not a tree right that's
just a point it's just a DOT it's a you
can't see the implications so the
veiling will then will then add the
implications of the Revelation uh and
the particularization of the Revelation
so that's why you need veils in order to
help you see something like you need you
need mediation and of course in the
Tabernacle that appears as the actual
veils in the temple that you have
different layers of veils that are
thickening from a from a um a linen Veil
all the way to like these Shaggy
garments of skin that are dyed red you
know on the outside of the Tabernacle
um and that's kind of the way to
understand how uh mediation function but
it's it's there and everything a good
another another an example is for
example Moses goes up to the mountain
Moses goes up to meet God and then God
will set up mediation between him and
the people you'll set up you know
leaders of a thousand leaders of a
hundred leaders of ten Etc so these are
mediations to to exemplify the aspect of
what is revealed at the top of the
mountain the law itself is that the law
is like God just says I am it's like
okay
I don't know what that means like I
don't know what that implies and so then
the I am becomes you know you will have
no other God before me you will make no
Idols you will you will you will cycle
the the time with meaning you will like
then it's like oh so that's what I am
means and then it keeps filtering down
into practices and laws and purification
rituals and all these things but it's
ultimately all rooted in the I am so
those are the mediations that appear you
know the problem of identity and
mediation is the best way to understand
it is that through these let's say
specification of of the revelation
well
well I find this so exciting because as
I think you know my background is in
sociology and there's a long history of
a study of ritual and art but what I
often found missing in sociology was the
word that you began by mentioning which
was Revelation and I wonder Beyond the
work that you do as an artist
what led you to found the symbolic World
project like who are you arguing with
when you're saying that reality comes to
us veiled that there's an element of
Revelation because I hear who you're
arguing with right and you're arguing
with on the one hand a kind of really
radical human human empiricism that all
of reality is contained in the movement
like a billiard balls hitting each other
like that's all this kind of crass
empiricism
and then on the other hand I think maybe
you're arguing also with people who
think that the meaning of symbols is in
relation to other symbols right that
symbol this symbol you know signifies
something but there's no signifier
behind any of those symbols right so
just what led you to found a whole
project dedicating to helping people
understand the meaning of symbols and
who's who's arguing with you I was
arguing with me so I think that you know
for those who who haven't followed my
work this this project is done very much
in collaboration with my brother Matthew
pejo who wrote a book called the
language of creation just plugging that
it's an amazing book by the way and I
think that it in our 20s you know we
grew up in a very we grew up in a
Protestant World a kind of Evangelical
Christianity which was very zealous and
had a lot of energy to it but was also
quite materialistic in its suppositions
uh and so then when we came to
University and came to Higher Learning
we kind hit a wall and had to account
for these crazy stories in scripture
um you know
and then diving back into tradition
diving back into the church fathers you
know into rabbinical thinking into
medieval thinking in general iconography
we started to notice that in fact you
know what these stories are what these
images are are just revealing us the
patterning of reality so the problem
with empiric is and the problem even
with like realist artists is that they
don't under they seem to not realize
that you always have to frame you can't
avoid the frame so if you're an artist
you know that right it's like when
you're looking at something even if
you're representing it with the most
immediacy that you can you still have to
reduce it you still have to frame it you
still have to contain it within a limit
and it's like so that frame is something
like attention it's something like
what's important so you know
contemporary artists try to play with
that try to break it as much as possible
right they try to represent things which
usually don't gather your attention or
that are that are broken and fragmentary
you know ironic there's all these ways
of contemporary trying to frame it but
it's still calling back to the problem
of framing to the problem of attention
so once you understand that it's like
okay well then what makes us care about
things and you realize that there's an
actual pattern to that it's not
arbitrary and what makes what what
appears as the center of attention what
appears as distraction you could say so
that's one way of framing it but then
you realize that it ends up being
honestly just the pattern of everything
that there basically is a pattern of how
reality let's say reveals itself to us
uh and and that you can you can
coherently see it and you can help
people understand it so that they no
longer think that
you know religious rituals are arbitrary
or that religious images and stories or
just ridiculous arbitrary stories but
rather they are patterning like ritual
for example it's so important to
understand that action is the same as
perception it's like you have to frame
actions you can't you don't just act in
the world you act in a directed way in
the directed way in which you act
implies an order of action
and so brushing your teeth is a ritual
right it has to be a ritual it has to be
in order so anything you do as a human
that has purpose is ritualized so once
you understand that and you think like
well then then I can explain religious
rituals to you in a way that you should
understand because you know everything
you do is ritualized you just cannot
avoid of of action that that it implies
to do anything with meaning
right well now let me you know so what I
hear you saying is that I actually
didn't realize that you had grown up in
a kind of Evangelical Protestant world
with this kind of strong emphasis
probably on you know the heart and
devotion and knowing scripture but then
trying to then later on grapple with
strange stories in the Bible especially
in the Old Testament trying to Grapple
with the Persistence of certain kinds of
rituals or you know the meaning of the
Eucharist and the Really symbolic
structure of the Christian faith right
and that Christian faith itself is not
purely rationalistic or law based
there's a kind of attraction to a
mystery as well that's there but then if
there's an attraction to the mystery
I've often wondered how do I know that
that mystery is real versus made up
right you said that it's really
important for people to understand that
religious rituals aren't arbitrary that
there are patterns of reality that are
unveiled through those and we can
approach that mystery maybe never fully
but we can approach it with trust that
we're going to discover more about
our own memory our own identity and not
just a kind of arbitrarily assigned
meaning of signs is that a good way no
you're you're absolutely right and I
think that most people today can access
that it's not that hard so for example
you can I always try to go as low as
possible you don't like it's hard to
talk about the Eucharist in a
materialist world because like what it's
too far it's like so high that it
becomes people can't see it but if you
talk about shaking hands with someone
and you say shaking hands has a pattern
it has a reality to it and it's not
there's variability like it wouldn't
have to necessarily be shaking hands but
it could be something like slapping each
other in the face like slapping each
other in the face could not re we could
not uh be a let's say a ritual of
communion because it has a certain form
it has a certain way of of uh acting on
on each other that is objectively true I
could also not turn my back to the
person like if I wanted to talk to
someone and meet them and I said well my
ritual for that is turning my back to
them well it's like no that's a
universally universally unacceptable way
of encountering someone so there are
actual parameters by which we engage
with each other these are not arbitrary
doesn't mean that they're all the same
there's flexibility and so if you can
scale that up and you can realize that a
family meal needs to have a certain
structure you can't have anything happen
at the family meal and I tell people if
you don't think that just try stepping
up standing up on the table just once
see what happens right it's like family
meals have a ritualized dance that
functions and so do feasts and you know
anything we do together and it's like
that scales up into a church and into a
into the Eucharist and I I mean I could
go through all the steps to show you how
the Eucharist is in some ways the source
or the highest version of eating
together but you can at least see see
that it's not arbitrary like these these
rituals that we engage with are are
based on the way our attention works the
way that you know our human interaction
works the way that we bind together as
Society is that we can't bind in a
society around anything you can like you
can but it will have effects like you
can bind as a group around smoking crack
like you can do that and people do like
people do will bind in groups around
smoking crack but the the fruits of that
will be coherent with the purpose for
which they're Binding Together
and it's like so it's like the idea that
we're Binding Together right in the
Incarnation under the god of love that's
there's it's like it's not arbitrary why
we're doing that these are coherent
images and rituals we participate in
all right that was fantastic listen you
know to build on that I think you're
right sometimes the modern world talking
about the Eucharist of people who've not
encountered it sounds like really
woo-woo what are you doing there well
one way that I one other topic that I
have struggled to talk about in the
modern world is Mary the Mother of God
the Blessed Virgin Mary I was I was
raised Catholic my mother is here on
this call I went to Catholic school we
had Devotion to the Rosary in the home I
never really thought much about this may
processions and those kinds of things
um but I also really didn't know how to
explain
Mary in faith or marry an art and you
know fast forward many years and I've
now encountered popular devotions to
marry in Haiti which was what my first
book was about
um in you know Fatima Portugal these
pilgrimage sites and there was something
about this enduring popular devotion to
Mary that that's super interesting
and then I get to Princeton Theological
Seminary and it turns out that you know
I was actually really afraid when I
taught Robert Orsi's book the Madonna of
115th Street which is about popular
devotion to Mary amongst Italian
Americans I was afraid that my
Protestant students were going to be
like this is all really out of touch
with modern world and it's not true
Christianity it was actually more like
can you can you tell me more about Mary
um can you and so I ended up teaching an
entire course on the Virgin Mary here at
Princeton Theological Seminary I'm
teaching it again starting tomorrow some
of my students in that class are here
with us today and what kind of hook that
maybe will make all of this stuff we're
talking about identity memory Community
you know why
is the Virgin Mary and the symbolism
around the Virgin Mary so powerful in
Revelation and so for me what aha moment
listening to you and then I went back
and studied this a little bit in Aiden
Hart's book on the festival icons and in
one of the books I teach in my class
which is on the development of Marian
Doctrine
um and all of these names for Mary so
one of the recurring images of Marian
art is Mary and the burning bush right
the burning bush is a story I believe
well you know why don't you tell us like
what is the story of the burning bush
and how is this Old Testament story of
God and the Burning Bush related to to
Mary the Mother of God like right so so
the start of the burning bush is that
Moses when he left Egypt the first time
he kills an Egyptian and has to flee
into into the the Wilderness you know he
becomes a Shepherd
um and then on the Mountain of God as he
sees on the on the Mountain of God he
notices this this
burning bush and so what it is it's a
it's a thorn bush that is burning but is
not being consumed
and so Moses approaches the bush and
then he hears a voice which tells him to
remove his sandals for this place is a
Holy Ground this ground is a Holy Ground
and so he removed his sandal and
approaches the burning bush and it is in
the burning bush or through the burning
bush that he receives the name of God
and uh it is in the in the Bible it is
the first time that God Reveals His name
to the people and so uh you know the god
of Abraham Abraham knew of God and had
different appellations for God different
names for God uh but here God Reveals
His name as the one who is right as the
I am
um and so why is it a burning bush and
why is it not being consumed so there's
a there's a problem in the problem of
mediation which is that
there's a sense you see that in
scripture right the idea that God would
consume the world like if God was in the
world he would consume it because the
infinite cannot fit in the finite it's
just pretty simple equation you try to
fit the infinite in the finite you blow
it apart right you just explode it and
so if you try to like and and it's not
like it how can I say this
if you try to fit the essence of
basketball in just dribbling
just dribbling can't hold the essence of
basketball
you need all these other things to
mediate basketball and you can't fit the
identity of something in one of its
elements it's not a it's not like a
magical thing it's just like that's how
reality works you can't you just can't
do it right and so and so the problem so
much of the problem with the Bible then
how do we encounter God
how does God mediate into the world if
the origin of reality can't fit in
reality
so you have this problem which is that
you need mediations those mediations
kind of show you God but they're also
distance from God so how do we deal with
this so what happens in the burning bush
is this mysterious moment
because it's a thorn bush
it's it is multiplicity itself right
that's what the thorn bush is it's like
a bunch of spikes it's all these
multiple multiple spikes and it's
actually in in scripture the thorn bush
is the consequence of the Fall so when
Adam Falls God says the Earth will
produce thorns
and so it's like you fell from unity and
now you will be lost in multiplicity
yeah right you'll be lost in this and
all these spiky spiky points let's say
instead of one point you've got spiky
points so and so now this mystery of God
appearing in the multiplicity
right in creation itself and not
consuming it so what is going on like
how is this possible and there is this
like this call for a mystery of how the
world can contain the presence of God
and it's not totally answered right in
the burning bush like why is this how is
this possible what is happening you know
but there is this kind of call to
mystery and so the sense of why then the
burning bush represents the Virgin is to
understand the question of space and the
question of place
for the Revelation so every time you'll
see a revelation in scripture every time
they'll be the Revelation and they'll be
the container or the space in which the
Revelation uh manifests itself
and that space is important and it's
mysterious because of the problem of God
blowing up reality because the problem
of that which is above not being able to
fit in that which is below and so what
happens is this image of the burning
bush becomes you know one of the one of
the early images of what it means the
possibility of God being in the world
without consuming it
that in some ways God has made the world
in a way that he can manifest himself in
creation without consuming it and that
is represented as you know there are
different ways of represent it it's
Purity it's uh it's something like uh
you know if you have this first image in
in the Bible as you know the spirit of
God and the waters below so it can be
like the waters or this idea of Purity
or this idea of
um you know something that is reflective
sometimes you have this image of like
the God is under his feet there's a
there's a sea of glass or a sea of of
precious stones that reflects his glory
back up so there's all these images and
it's like that's what Mary will
ultimately become as the container as
the Ark of the Covenant as you know the
Tabernacle as the burning bush as the
mountain as the latter and it's like all
these images that we use about Mary is
to talk about the way in which the world
ultimately mysteriously the is capable
God has made it in a way that is capable
to become a vehicle for his presence
all right so the idea if I understood
you correctly idea that to the extent
there is something that's infinite it
would make sense that the infinite can't
fit into the finite right so we need
some kind of mediation in order to see
the to perceive to encounter in some way
the infinite and so the burning bush
something in nature that's burned but
not consumed is kind of pointing to this
infinity and then Mary now walk us
through this a little bit more Mary as
the burning bush why she's the bush
she's she's the space so Mary is always
the space of Revelation so she's not the
Revelation herself it's really important
by the way to make the distinction it's
like that's why in Orthodox theology we
will always represent the mother of god
with the child right so it's like the
space and the glory so she's the Ark of
the Covenant and the glory of God
descends on on the ark so in in any
Revelation there are those two aspects
you could say something like the
masculine and feminine aspects of the
Revelation one which is that which comes
from heaven and then that which receives
it or manifests it below and so Mary is
that she's the throne that's why she's
represented as the The Throne of wisdom
so these early images of Mary represent
her has as a throne with Christ sitting
on her and with his head over her heart
and you see that in the images of the
panagia where she's you know in the the
Orthodox churches for example she has
her arms out like this and then in her
Center she'll have the Divine logo
shining through her right appearing out
of her and so that's that's in that
image he's an image of the burning bush
as well right it's like so you imagine
the burning bush and then the glory of
God you know let's say revealing itself
through that space through that Divine
that Holy space
well since you mentioned also the Virgin
kind of with her with her arms open yeah
what are some other I mean the burning
bush is one what are some other
prototypes of Marian art what by which I
mean some kind of recurring images of
Mary in Christian art so the the first
image images that we know of Mary is an
image called the horogetria which is the
image of the mother holding Christ on
her and showing us Christ with her right
hand and so usually you'll see it it's
actually one of the most famous images
and so she she holds Christ and she
she's showing us and sometimes she's
she's usually bowing her head slightly
you know and so it's like it's the one
who's showing the way and you can
understand that right you can understand
it as Mary herself but then also at the
possibility of outward signs or of holy
places or of prayers or whatever it is
that's external pointing inwards like
pointing towards the Revelation and so
she becomes in a way in a way an image
of the church itself which which is
pointing to Christ right it's like
that's the whole point of why we're
Christians we're we're pointing to
Christ we're little we're like
specifications of of the Revelation in
our own lives was supposed to embody
some aspect of Christ and so you can
understand that like I said as as her of
course directly doing that but then
ultimately I mean she's the one who says
at the winning of Kana listen to what my
son says that's her role she she points
people towards her son
um and and so and so like I said it is
also in some ways an image the proper
relationship of understanding the
outward with the inner like the the
outward aspect of anything and the inner
aspect of anything
you know okay
okay so the the Inward and the outward
you know Jonathan when I started to do
the research to teach this class in the
Virgin Mary well first of all I
discovered going to the Princeton
Theological Seminary there are two
thousand years of books about Mary
um so there's a lot of mariology and
then I went over to the index of
Christian art or the index of medieval
art here at Princeton University and
discovered similarly there's really two
thousand years of art of
and you know what struck me going into
the index that there's not that much art
about other women in the Bible although
other women appear in the Bible I'm not
saying there isn't any but there's not
that much so this leads me to my other
question just do you have any idea I
mean when we talk about the Virgin Mary
you know that well that's the word I was
always taught to call her you know the
Virgin Mary right Purity virginity these
are not really culturally you know
popular words right now one might say
but my question is what explains the
enduring devotion
to marry the mother of God above and
beyond other women in the Bible like why
why is there two thousand years of art
about marriage why does Mary appear in
all of these different countries
speaking to people in in their own
tongues what is the enduring presence of
Mary across culture what does that tell
us
or she how can I say this she is the
embodiment like she's the source of body
is the guy I don't know who else to say
it and so because of that she's the one
who gave body to Christ maybe that's the
best way to think of that if if you
understand it's like Christ's body
doesn't come from anywhere else besides
her like that's out of which his body is
it comes and so
she becomes a stand-in for the church
for all of us she's a stand-in for all
of us that is she is that which gathers
us she's the one who gathers us
toward gathers Us in worship towards
Christ is a good way to understand it
right uh and so and so because of that
that's why also she can appear
in in let's say she will appear in
Visions as well because she is that so a
good example is of course I don't know
if you know the
she often appears in images of
protections for example a famous
Orthodox images the the veil of
protection so there's this in the
Constantinople someone had a vision of
her you know above the church and hold
putting her veil as a protection around
the church and so there are versions of
that in Catholic art where you've seen
you've probably seen these images where
you see the mother of God standing up
and then she has her cloak open and then
in her cloak is like standing all the
people right they're all gathered
together in her and so that's a good way
to understand it it's like she is that
she's the the Gathering of the body and
so she she stands in for the church
itself
well so you know one of the things that
I learned in teaching this class so Mary
is similar to what you said there are
lots of people and Prophets men and
women who have important roles in the
Bible but maybe part of what I heard you
say what explains the enduring
significance of Mary and popular
devotion and art is that the church the
body of Christ has to continuously be
recreated across space and time and
culture and to the extent what I heard
you say is that because Mary gave body
to Christ she also gathers the church
together in worship right she's there at
Pentecost she's there at the birth of
the church right and so the church has
to be continuously recreated through a
connection to this feminine presence is
that correct oh that's a good way to
understand it and it's important to
understand that in some ways she is very
much a mystery of the church and we
should be careful like
I mean it's okay to talk about her but
we have to be very cautious in talking
about her because she is something which
belongs to the church in some ways she's
interfacing she's inward facing because
she is that which gathers the church
together and so the mystery of the Holy
place and the Mystery of Sacred Space is
something which is very intimate and is
very and is very it's a almost secretive
and and that's important to understand
because if we don't understand that you
know because she's hidden in the New
Testament you know in some ways you
actually have to have certain keys in
order to understand her importance in
the New Testament you have to have some
intuition about you know
some inkling about the role of the
church and what's being set up in the
New Testament to see her importance in
the New Testament but at first glance
you know she's not that present in the
New Testament but I do think she's she's
def every Everything said about her in
the New Testament hides a thousand
Mysteries but you have to you have to
have you know the the the intuition and
the Gathering in the church to be able
to to see those Mysteries and to pierce
them
hmm
right so I I guess another question I
don't know if you've talked about this
in other spaces but one of the things
that often comes up in my class
um is that the presence of a feminine
Authority in the church right one of the
things about today is that people don't
really want to talk about roles
associated with masculinity or
femininity or male or female right
you're you're smiling here so
what I mean I don't have a problem
talking about it it's fine well then
let's talk about it okay what is it
about you know
so in the book that my students love
Robert orsi is Madonna of 115th Street
people do really relate to the
Italian-American grandmother yeah as a
kind of moral authority of the family
that's distinct from the public
authority of the man but what the
students find so interesting is that
when it comes down to it the most
important questions are the moral
questions and the woman has this kind of
reverence amongst the rest of the family
like decisions about the family and
marriage have to go through the Italian
grandmother right maybe I sound like I'm
stereotyping masculine and feminine male
and female but what are your thoughts
like what is the femininity of Mary and
how does that relate to femininity and
culture or should it um
no I think that that say the role and
the power of the feminine is represented
very much so in the story of Mary in
ways that sometimes people fail to see
um
the wedding Arcana is probably one of
the best examples if you want to kind of
understand the power of the feminine
it's one of those things where I guess
in some ways we have to talk about it
now because
the world is so the world is kind of off
tilt off kilter a little bit so we kind
of have to talk about it but it's the
type of things which probably should be
left implicit but anyways so in the
winning of Kana there's an interesting
moment you know because
there's this problem and the Virgin
comes up to Christ and she says to
Christ she says there's no wine
and what's Christ's answer it's the
craziest answer right he says my time
has not yet come it's like what
what so she's saying there's no why and
he's saying I am not ready to die yet
it seems like there's a problem of
communication
but there's not a problem of
it's like
she is open she is showing him the door
towards Revelation she is framing his
his coming public
and she's giving him the space in which
to make his first miracle
and so she is she's acting as a mother
right there she's saying
it's now
here's the moment here's the place
this is the question
and now Christ has to answer the
question
and so if you want to understand the
relationship between a question and an
answer
you know which one has more power
it's like think of think of uh think of
uh
the question frames the answer
the question provides the space provides
the direction
for the answer to come
right that's why we pray that's why we
think and so there's a deep deep
mysterious power
in the capacity to ask a question
um
and if we didn't think that we would we
wouldn't pray right uh and so
I can't ex I won't explain it to you but
there's a very very deep uh revelation
of the role of the feminine and the role
that that uh Framing and a question can
can play in in Revelation
I don't know if you ever you probably
have all seen My Big Fat Greek Wedding
but there's a very very wise thing that
said in that movie
you know there's a scene where the
mother is talking to her daughter and
she says to her daughter she says you
know the man is the head of the
household
but the woman is the neck
and she can make the head look in any
direction she wants
and it's like
that's what Mary do is that's what Mary
is doing at the wedding of Connor she's
doing exactly that she's saying here
look at this problem what are you going
to say now
and if you think of the relationship
between men and women you'll notice that
it actually seeps into so many aspects
of it's like the question of like would
men do anything if there weren't women
well so
I love that scene from My Big Fat Greek
Wedding it gives everyone I think an
image who's seen it to think on but I
think part of what linking back this
question to what you said earlier that
reality comes to us failed and it needs
to be unveiled that the masculine and
The Feminine in complementing each other
kind of point to this Unity but also a
mystery right that there's we cannot
equate masculine and feminist being
exactly the same without eradicating the
mystery of who we are right so this this
difference between masculine and
feminine or masculine and feminine
Authority or forms of influence reveals
that at the end humans aren't in charge
we are responsible to God that this this
difference points to the mystery is what
yeah but mystery so it's like we have a
it's important to understand what a
mystery is in terms of because we we
have these words that we use in
religious discourse it's like a mystery
is a puzzle that's what a mystery is a
mystery is a question that's why I I I'm
trying to help you understand that the
feminine is appears as a question that's
it's that's its role and that's what it
does it's like here the space like the
if you how can I say this like if you
build it they will come right this idea
that if you create the frame if you have
the frame and the question and the
Mystery then the Revelation appears on
the mystery this is something that you
know like in the very architecture of
the Tabernacle that's what you have the
glory of God descends on what descends
on these cherubs these cherubs are like
are like sphinxes they they have mixture
of different animal parts or whatever
it's the it's the question which frames
the answer and so it's important to
understand like I would say like when
you talk about unveiling I would
definitely be careful and I would say
that the Virgin is that is the one whose
Veil can never be removed
like you cannot remove her veil her veil
is the kind of like the Eternal Veil I
don't know what else to say she she
represents like the the very deep deep
mystery of Revelation uh and it's shown
in her story like more apocryphal
aspects of her story that
in the story of the uh in the the uh the
um
Pro evangelium uh you have this this
story of when the mother of God gives
birth to Christ she has these two
um these two women helping her uh one
whose name is Salome and Salome can't
believe the Virgin birth right and so in
the text if you read it she checked she
tries to check
if she's a virgin and her hand burns off
like your hand could it's very dramatic
as an image but there's a sense in which
in in which she cannot even see if the
veil is there like it's like the veil or
the veil of the Virgin
is not something to be trifled with like
it'll it is and so so anyways it's hard
because I'm taught using very kind of
cryptic language I don't want to that's
not I tried to make things as when I
explain things I try to make them as
simple and as accessible as possible but
but talking about Mary is difficult
because she she has very deep Mysteries
uh assigned to her let's say mm-hmm
well look I agree with you talking about
Mary is difficult having taught a class
on it and doing it again it's and
looking in the library of the books and
the images but
would you recommend are there any books
that you recommend are there any images
that you think is right I mean you make
images and images often express things
in a way that it's difficult to capture
in words do you have a couple of
prototypes of Marion art that you think
are really important to to have in the
house or to pray with or to meditate
prey on
I mean I think the image of the of the
panagia you know this image that we
talked about the the image of the of the
mother of God who has her hands out and
she's forming something like a cup she
she she's a rich she's a container right
for that which comes above and then you
have Christ appearing in her heart or
let's say manifesting himself in her
heart I think it's it's one of the
deepest images that that that Christians
have because in some ways you know like
I said in some ways Mary is a stand-in
for us you know it's like it's the hope
that we have right the hope that we have
that we can have Christ descend into our
heart when I that Christ can become the
the the the the heart the the center of
who we are you know and of course
liturgically that is true it's true
through the sacraments it's through
through the Eucharist but you know we
know that we have always have more that
we could access that we could have more
of that and that we could become even
more trans apparent to the glory of God
and and she was you know perfectly
transparent and I think to me that image
is really one of the most powerful
images uh
that we have I agree with you Jonathan
it's hard to put these things in words
because it feels like you're reducing
this great complex mystery to you know
it goes beyond words
um but yet words and images as you say
try to help us approach that mystery but
I'll be honest no other class that I've
taught is quite like the Virgin teaching
about the Virgin Mary and I've more
explicitly this time around included an
aspect of okay how does reading this
Theology and looking at these images how
does this impact your Devotion to the
mother of God because at the end these
ideas and the images are supposed to
help us on our on our personal Journey
which is a journey that we share with
other people but I don't want to over
intellectualize it or overturn it into
the cultural study of of art
um
so you know in terms of the
proto-evangelium since you brought that
up
um and a lot of the images from Marion
are come from that I know one person
wanted to ask and I've seen this in many
churches as well the significance of
what is the significance of of Mary um
of Mary with the with the yarn with sort
of sewing yeah well that's it yeah it
was a suggestion that she weaves the
temple veil herself yeah exactly and so
that's exactly it's it really is to
connect her with the notion of the of
the veil of that mystery
of the mystery and the Revelation and so
that's what that's what she that's why
she's shown as let's say weaving the the
temple veil so when you see her with a
piece of yarn that's what it's it's
signifying that she is that she is
mending the temple veil
yeah
and that's what she she that's what she
is in some ways
can you say a little bit more she is the
temple veil or she's mentioned she's she
yeah that's so
how can I say this it's like it's it's a
fractal thing so it's hard to it's hard
it's hard to explain but so she is she
is she is the
the mystery in which or out of which the
Revelation comes and so that mystery has
different aspects to it right it can be
the the let's say the uh the ark of the
covenant right that's this box and the
glory of God descends on the box you
know and so her womb plays that role
directly it's very direct but then
there's also
every level has these two aspects
together right every level of revelation
has in some ways of veil and an
unveiling or a veil and the manner in
which the veil also reveals that which
is behind it and she always plays the
role of the mystery at every at every
level
and so she's the veils of the the temple
uh she's the you know she's the
untouched Mountain you have this this
type of or the uncut Mountain for
example the space out of which things
happen
um and so it happens at many levels and
that's why she's also veiled herself
it's important to understand that's why
like
for example if you look at an image of
the Deus which is the basic image of
Christian iconography you have Christ in
the center as representing the king you
know the son of man all of that type of
imagery and then to his right there's
the Virgin who is veiled
and then to his left there's Saint John
the Baptist who is wild crazy hair you
know wearing garments of skin and and
you can almost understand that she it's
like she represents that
the veil let's say or the hidden the
secret all of that type of stuff and he
represents like the guy out in the
desert screaming like repent repent you
know he there's nothing secret about
Saint John the Baptist and uh and he has
a kind of uh directness you know he's
willing he's talking about cutting the
tree down like repent or you're gonna
get thrown into the fire like that kind
of language but Mary she's
she has this she has the secretive
aspect to herself
the mystery the mysterious aspect of it
let's say
okay
so you know we've got about 10 minutes
left and I hope to get back to some of
the questions about symbolic meaning in
Mary if we have time but a number of
people on the call today are artists
right and so some if we could get some
questions about your vocation as an
artist or your how you understand your
your work as an artist so for example
um one person wants to know like well
how is it that an artist in a way
unveils or acts as a mediator is it
appropriate for an artist to think that
that's what they're doing I mean are
there aspects of artistic style that
emerge through partial abstraction
um like or deviation from strict
National appearance
natural appearances as through the
content of an image yeah well the the
first thing to get out of your mind is
the idea that you can represent what's
out there you can't no one can there's
that that's that's a that's a joke like
anybody who thinks they're being
naturalistic is just it's ridiculous
you're not being naturalistic even even
by the simple fact of framing anything
you are Contracting it reducing it
there's no way and you're pointing
attention towards it so
now levels of abstraction can have a
role you know in directing attention is
the best way to understand it so if you
if you look at something that is highly
abstract not in the modern sense but
let's say in terms of representing a
cross as an ornament or representing an
ornamental or or highly typified image
of an anchor like the old ancient
Christians would be these are abstracted
in the sense that they are
they are pointing your attention more
like the more you abstract something the
more you're capable of pointing
attention uh and it's different from the
type modern abstraction I'm almost on
purpose doing this to you uh which is
that the the level that which you show
in an image should be related to what
it's doing and what it should be related
to what it is you want to do in terms of
attention and in terms of participation
and some images
have some images levels of abstraction
have always existed in art this is not a
modern phenomena they've existed from
time immemorial and they still exist
today but the the difficulty with
Contemporary Art and Modern Art is that
they don't they don't necessarily ask
themselves what function is this image
playing in order for me to engage in
this level of abstraction
um and like I said you know abstract art
or geometric art for example is abstract
but it all it has a function so I would
say that the artist
is I say what what's important what's
interesting about the artists is I think
the artist can become more than others
aware of mediation and veiling you can't
avoid it but you when you're making
something you become so you can become
very aware
that you are acting as a mediator
between things that you are Contracting
that you're Gathering aspects of reality
together right you're taking color paint
you're taking wood or stone and you're
bringing it together in order to
gather people's attention towards it
it's like that's something that we
should be very careful about and it's a
it's in some ways it's a
right it's almost a magical position
that we're in and so we have to be we
have to be very careful because it's
very powerful
most people aren't aware of the things
that I'm talking about most people
aren't aware that reality has to be
framed that things have to be brought
together in order for you to notice them
artists just
inevitably become aware of it because
they're doing it all the time
right you're constantly framing things
and constantly mediating them and
Contracting them and deciding what to
leave in what to leave out you know all
of this type of work that you're doing
uh is is the experience of mediation
itself
so it's impossible to be purely
naturalistic
mediating and you have to be extremely
careful about it because as an artist
what I hear you saying is that the very
Act of making art is an active mediation
of reality and that can impact People
based on based on what you create so to
approach this with with a sense of real
responsibility and another question that
some of the artists have asked is how do
aspiring artists who want to do work in
the kind of vein that that you do where
do you find Community how do you find
the Human Relationships the the
formation to persevere in this kind of
career for someone who feels this
calling to be the kind of person you're
talking about how did you do it
I mean where
we're in a strange situation you know
it's like I I see a few people in here I
saw David uh is here David Clayton you
know we're in this we were in a strange
situation we kind of came out of
Contemporary Art and in some ways we
were in a highly irregular world and so
you know it's like the idea of becoming
an iconographer was so difficult and so
strange uh that that we almost had to
jump start something which was almost
dead maybe that's the best way to
explain it like Aiden Hart is a good
example of that too it's like we came in
a world where these practices had been
almost forgotten and had been cast aside
and so
us and maybe a few people that came just
before us in some ways we're we're
restarting something that that was lost
so I think that we're in a better
position right now I think there's at
least now you have people that you can
recognize as as Masters that can at
least show the way you know that you can
learn from either take seminars with or
that you can at least look at the
writings they've done like Aiden has
written a wonderful book like his book
on icon painting is a masterful book to
help anybody along that that path
um but I would say that ultimately it's
important to also be connected to to the
church you don't if you want to make
sacred art there's you shouldn't just be
on your own making sacred art like you
really should be
you should be sacramentally connected to
to the church you should be involved and
you should be doing it to some extent
with the blessing of your Spiritual
Authority
um you know that's a little tricky at
least at least when you start you know
it's I think it's fine to take classes
without the blessing of your priests
some priests might disagree with me but
if you want to start doing it
professionally or doing it publicly then
you need to kind of insert yourself into
that that family and participate in that
family uh because you also need checks
and balances like you need people to be
able to uh to tell you that know that
image no like it's just not we're not
it's not acceptable uh so yeah
you know we were speaking last night
David Clayton who's my husband he and I
were speaking last night to Peter Carter
we'll also be at the scholar conference
in April who he'll be leading the the
music the liturgical music the praying
of the Liturgy of the Hours and he
started a group called the Catholic
Sacred Music project and he was also
saying hey look things are a lot better
than they used to be and I said you know
if we're going to compare now to the 70s
yeah it is better so but
um I think your point is well taken I
think people like you people like David
Clayton Peter Carter Aiden Hart all of
us will be together at the scholar
conference represent that there there is
a rebirth of interest in liturgical Arts
sacred art Sacred Music and Scala hopes
to be able to provide some of the
connections amongst people who are doing
this kind of work that's why we host
these online events that's why we
publish the books we have we have blogs
we're trying to share the wonderful work
that you're doing Jonathan I wanted to
introduce people to you I encourage
people to just listen to your videos
subscribe to your uh to your uh YouTube
channel read your blog it is maybe not
you know yet spreading wildly but there
are a lot more artists doing this kind
of work than when you and David and
Aiden started there's more ways to get
trained but your point about staying
connected to the church and staying
connected to prayer is just such good
life advice for anybody who feels that
they have a vocation from God it doesn't
mean it's going to be easy and staying
connected to the sacraments into the
church and to a community of Faith
um
I just want to say one last thing just
to maybe wrap up like the the connection
to the mother of God also is that you
know
there's a there's a there's a reason why
often the first icon that was made the
tradition that the first icon that was
made was an image of the mother of God
painted by Saint Luke and you know these
are of course deeply kind of traditional
legendary stories but they the fact that
this is
that's the structure of the story it's
important to help us understand the role
of the mother God in liturgical art
because in some ways we are
exteriorizing something hidden or
something secret we are giving body to
the tradition of the church when we are
making uh images when we're building
churches all these things we're giving
body to to the to the church and to the
tradition of the church and so that's
why there is a deep relationship between
the artist and the making of these
things and the participation and
embodiment that with the with with Mary
herself and so I think it's not at all
arbitrary that that she was the first
one represented in an icon
when you're talking about your vocation
as an artist and the sort of the calling
to mediate reality to represent people
to do that in a way where you're
connecting also your own spiritual walk
to the mother of God is that what I was
here
well that she in some ways is an image
of the art of the art itself like she's
an image of the the practice of this
Gathering of things together like when
you're when you're taking you're
Gathering elements together and you're
bringing there's a beautiful image of of
one of the most I think powerful
the most powerful secrets in scripture
is when Mary uh she sees the wise men
come to to to see her and you know she
has all these experiences and it says
she says Mary gathered all these things
in her heart
and it's like that's it like that's what
she does she gathers these elements she
gathers stories she gathers elements of
the world together to give body and
that's what we do as artists right We
Gather
We Gather color and and stuff together
into bodies so so that's why I think
that that she's so important for the she
was so important in the the stories
about how sacred art was born in the
church
that's fantastic I didn't know that
Jonathan I had not made that connection
I will bring that up with my students
thank you to all of you who have pasted
these wonderful links in the chat button
this was a very active chat I'm really
sorry that we can't get into everybody's
questions because we're out of time but
I will invite you once again to the
Scala conference April 21 and 22 in
Princeton New Jersey register to come in
person or if you can't come in person
please do register online uh Jonathan's
talk is going to be on memory and the
role of Art and identity and then he'll
have a follow-up conversation with David
Clayton and also with Paul Courier of
the Common Sense Society Aiden Hart will
also be speaking and he's going to be
focusing his talk on the role of of Art
in upholding human dignity and showing
the face of the person as created in the
image of God and why that matters so
much for the modern world we'll also
have Peter Carter as I mentioned we'll
also have Anna Bond who's a graphic
designer and the co-founder with her
husband of rifle paper company which
some of you might have seen some of
their stationery so she's going to talk
about the vision behind her her brand in
art
um so thank you Jonathan for your time
thank you everybody for being here and I
hope everybody leaves inspired to both
to really Ponder and gather and create
and I have great admiration for your
work as an artist Jonathan and for the
incredible work you're doing to spread
this vision of art as enabling Humanity
mediating reality while really standing
I think in awe in front of the mystery
of God's revelation which is bigger than
our Awards or our art could ever fully
capture so thank you yeah thanks to you
this has been wonderful and I'm looking
forward to to meeting all of you or some
of you at the conference so thanks
everyone